Okay you now have all the pieces you
need to finish the parallel algorithm.
The only piece that's left
is this process level.
Remember that bag splits
are very efficient.
Therefore we should try to use our
favorite scheme, divide and conquer.
So here's some pseudo code that
implements exactly a divide and
conquer scheme.
It's got two parts,
first the input bag is big enough
then we do divide and conquer.
Using splitting.
If the bag is not big enough,
then we just fall back, essentially,
to the sequential code.
Now, the one difference is
this parallel for loop.
So let's see how that works.
So again, given a bag at level L,
the first step is to split
it if the bag is big enough.
Since we can process the elements
in any order we can use divide and
conquer on the two halves.
And I said the base case was the same
as the sequential algorithm, but
I planned out this one difference.
The difference is this neighbor loop.
Notice that i'm iterating over
the neighbors using a parallel
four instead of a conventional four.
Now that might give you pause because
there might be tasks trying to update
the same neighbor W, but since were
using a level synchronize album
all those updates are going to be
doing this exact same thing which
is writing the value of L
plus 1 into the D of W.
So even though there's a data race here,
it's actually perfectly safe.
Now the bag inserts are trickier.
And for those,
we're going to have to exploit the fact
that bags are logically associative, and
therefore we can use these reducer hyper
objects that we talked about earlier.
Okay, we're almost done.
The last thing we need to do,
is analyze the cost.
Now, the cost analysis is really tricky,
so
if you want all of the gory details, I
refer you to the paper by Lyzer-shin and
Shettle, which we posted
on the instructor's notes.
For now, let's just sketch the analysis.
First, I'm going to claim that
the algorithm is work-optimal.
If you want to go into details again,
please see the paper.
Now what about the span?
The The span is effected by
a couple different factors.
The first factor is
the number of levels,
that's essentially
the outer most while loop.
Of course the while
loop is not shown here
that was the pseudo code that was on
the left side of the screen earlier.
The second factor is
the span of process level.
Now the first factor we said was
bounded by the diameter of the graph.
let's call it little d.
The span of process
level has three parts.
There's the depth of the recursion,
there's the cost of splitting and
then there's the cost of the base case.
Now the recursion will be
logarithmic in the size of Fl.
And since Fl can only be
the total number of vertices,
in the worst case the depth of
recursion should be log in.
The splitting we argue was log in,
now what about the base case?
Now in the base case,
the size of Fl is a constant,
because we have a constant cut-off
built in as we usually do,
therefore we can bound
this by a constant.
So let's put that all together.
It will turn out that the cost is
basically bounded by the diameter and
something that's polylogrithmic
in the size of the graph.
And we love polylogrithmic,
so we're done.
>> Yay.
[APPLAUSE]